Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to Pacific
Now this is a pixelated style horror game in the genre of I'm scared and various games like that
I haven't played one of these games in a long time
Eh..
Moreover being that there haven't been one of these games in a long time, but they often lead into dark and terrifying situations
Likes of which you've never seen before hello, hi
Okay, why?
*weird music*
I don't like that, what was that
Excuse you
Hi, okay. You gonna do something to me cuz I don't know if I want it
Alright, okay. Oh, fucking hi okay. Ok, that's gonna be huh oh
Whoa? Oh okay? Hi, how long have you been there have I just been stupid oh
But your locked so doesn't matter oh?
Okay, hey, come on. Now. Don't do this to me
*radio static*
thousands of Peace
Or it seems that by the possession of such deadly weapons
peace can be maintained in this troubled world.
*trumpets play in background*
*clicks off*
I don't know if that sounds like peace to me but ok. Is this unlocked?
Oh ok. Loverly that is.
Oh, hello.
survival under atomic attack
Great. I'd love that, but am I going to be haunted by demons in exchange. What happens if I close the door?
Ah, safe.
Great.
ah, Oh
Okay, all right
eh, hehehehehe... eh
Back where I thought I was what happens if I close this door. Oh, is that how I changed it. Oh, oh
ahh
oh
OOHHHH
Oh, Cooky pookie
oooooo
o
Hi
oh, okay, all, all right, oh okay
ehh
Okay
Did something happened during the-     OHH HI all righty, then a little weird, but okay?
Hello?
Oh good, convenient!
*radio static*  *mavn rocs fos time rocs where no man lives*
Coveted by winds blowing in from the ocean. This is the place chosen to explode britain's first atomic weapon.
Okay, Britain's first atomic weapon. That's good for britain, but what does that mean for me?
OH, You're gone now, okay?
Frick... ahhh
Yes
Excellent. I shall close the door and then I shall
ooohhhhh, hohoho!
it didn't change this room at all. Ah it did okay never-
ok- ahhhhhhhoookay.
ALL right, I know what I'm being dicked with and I expressly don't like being dick wi-
I didn't expect that to move
Okay, well I pushed a chair around. I think I worked out my aggression
*gasp*
*whispers* ok
Everything's fine ah good my beds
Do I duck in cover under this is there someone - oh my God there's people here. There's people on the beds. I didn't know that
Ahh.
Didn't know that at all.
OhHHh oh
*rapid footsteps*
Hi
Another body mushroom of slain and covered ash is a trail of Devastation such as the world has never known
Here and there an isolated struchture reminds the on looker, that here was once a city
Kay
Great
Cool.
oh look! another one!
is it gonna be-- AAAHHHHHYYY
hummmm
Gotta put up my defenses huh *mumbles*
Fuck you
Doing pieces of shit you think you scare me? No! Oh, it's a door now...
Ah good. I'll just hide in the closet scuse me you still there never mind. You're locked good. You just want some privacy under your covers
*loud banging on door*
Okay, you know what I'm gonna. Go down this Hallway, and never OOHH righty then
Hello, I
Well, this is very helpful swonk some here. Oh
Stairs, I like a stairs. Oh, Goody
I don't like the sound of that, One minute to go slowly the seconds tick away
Okay, I can't, I don't know what you want from me oh
Every second I turn a corner I get disappointed oh
Hi, okay. I don't know what all right, then why it's you sure okay back down the stairs
We go, then is it wet down here I?
I don't know what it wants from me. Did that turn on a light. Ah good. It did, it unlocked it. I think
All right here we go
Why
Ugh
I don't like this, thank you, I got that in my pocket now oh good. You gonna rise
ah
Is this looping forever
It's looping forever, oh it's not
Christine has pointed out that it would be unfair to abandon while she alone and the three great powers had no H bomb of their own
Perhaps, it will be easy to reach agreement on this controversial problem. Now that America Russia and Britain stand on a deep level
Sure, great, back I go then
Okay
This is oh hi. Thank you for playing?!
Made in twenty-nine hours?!
What at Dan that Dan Taiwan. I don't know
What your just gonna of leave it at that? I didn't even know this was a game Chan game
How did you make this in 24 hours that was incredible that actually the end?
What happened to me? Good god that was amazing!
Well, that's how it is with these pixilated horror games,  you never know what you're gonna get but when it works
It's amazing!
I guess that's the end
So I'm just gonna say good bye in this room full of bodies
So thank you everybody so much for watching everyone check out Dan on Twitter
And Dan keep this up. This was really something special it ended too soon
You made this in 29 hours think of what you could do with a couple weeks. Oh
Anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought it found the comments below
And as always I will see
you in the next video!
bye-bye !